Let me show you a handy tool: Google Cloud Shell.
To start up cloud shell click on the terminal icon in Google Cloud Console.
At the bottom of your screen a terminal appears.
This terminal is connected to a small temporary Linux VM
You can use this terminal to do normal management tasks like
creating VMs or storage buckets, building Docker images, or accessing
your Cloud SQL DB.
The VM that is created has most of the tools you need to work on your application
including text editors
and compliers or interpreters for Go, Java, Python, Ruby, and Node.js
I find Cloud Shell to be especially helpful when I'm on the road.
Hotel and conference wifi can be spotty but my Cloud Shell instance
is sitting in a Google data center so it is great for doing the heavy handed tasks
involved in managing my projects.
I hope you try out Cloud Shell soon.